[Musique]
vous êtes là
nous avons un petit problème pour lequel
nous avons besoin de VOUS Mobius
voilà voilà ce qui se passe constamment
temporel quoi vous connaissez ça oui
vous avez déjà vu ça oui vous pouvez
arranger ça non les rangs temporelles
n'existent pas dans le TVA je sais et
pourtant c'est bien ce qu'on vient de
voir
baladé dans le flux temporel
promener entre le passé et le présent
qui est là
et si ce que j'ai fait
alors plus rien ne protège ce monde de
la destruction totale
il n'y a qu'un moyen de le savoir
et on se la joie à l'ancienne comme dans
le temps nous n'avons pas le même style
vous êtes un homme d'action ce que je
respecte
j'ai une approche plus lente délibérée
et cérébrale que vous
c'est vraiment excellent
[Musique]
c'est à nous
de sauver le TVA
c'est bon
quoi qu'on fasse
on se prend pour des dieux
qui vit
et qui meurt
faites le choix le plus douloureux
[Musique]
vous êtes le dieu de la malice
vous serez à jamais on ne se rendait pas
[Applaudissements]
je crois que vous en faites un peu trop
je trouvais ça approprié